[Musique]
y compris le 31 décembre
on ne pourra pas sortir après 20h à plus
de cent mille agents des forces de
l'ordre je serai moi même auprès d'eux
ce 31 décembre pour contrôler si elle
récidive je crois que c'est 1500 euros
que c'est ça non non alignement 200
euros je sens les quinze jours et après
dans les 15 jours et après 6,3
infections trois infractions dans les 30
jours après je crois qu'on arrive à 1500
noms et dites-moi 3700 3710 mois selon
fo aujourd'hui j'ai acheté pif gadget
pardon pif le max et son nouveau nom
selon le président du conseil
scientifique
le virus n'est pas près d'arrêter de
circuler il ne faut donc surtout pas
baisser la garde à la proche des fêtes
la science avance dans le silence mais
elle avance en attendant restons
extrêmement prudents encore trois à six
mois
c'est le dernier effort est les petits
pois sauteurs mexicain la machine à
faire des écarts et les lunettes
d'espions avec les miroirs pour regarder
derrière et puis des grandes signatures
de la bande des signes comme hugo pratt
et oui les aventures de corto maltese
c'était dans pif gadget tout comme les
aventures de rabbi cette génération là
qu'elle connaît les glandes go les
trente glorieuses qu'à profiter des
ouais j'ai fait un peu la porte mais
j'ai un truc cette génération qui a
connu les trente glorieuses quart de la
croissance à 2 points qu'à profiter des
trente glorieuses
ils viennent nous expliquer que nous
faut qu'on arrête de bosser faut qu'on
arrête de vive il faut qu'on arrête de
gagner des sous quoi moi j'avais parlé
avec des responsables de la presse
communiste à l'époque et je leur ai
demandé mais en quoi puis faisaient
petit gadget un rapport avec les idées
du parti communiste il m'avait dit si un
rapport oui parce que le héros qui
s'appellera ans un homme préhistorique
défend comme il ya une certaine
conception de la raison contre les
préjugés l'obscurantisme de cette époque
reculée agence européenne du médicament
a communiqué sur une décision qui sera
rendue le 21 décembre
et dans la foulée dans les jours qui
suivront les autorités de santé
nationales rendre
leur avis et puis nous pourrons démarrer
une vaccination vous avez le portable du
premier ministre mais bien sûr mais je
connais très bien premier mini jeux vous
rappelle qui était directeur de cabinet
oui bien sûr le trajet mais c'est du
mauvais temps j'attends toujours qu'ils
agissent derrière les premières
vaccinations pourraient donc être
réalisés dès la dernière semaine du mois
de décembre avant de monter en puissance
à partir de début janvier dit olivia
ruiz hésite parce que je transmettrai le
message vous transmettra uba il n'y a
pas besoin vous savez pourquoi ils
écoutent tous leurs joueurs être et sur
l'iphone c'est lui ils écoutent tous ces
news de matériel il ya la nécessité de
la rigueur on va y être mais laissez les
autorités réglementaires européennes
pour ce qui nous concerne finir leur
travail ils vont le finir dans les jours
qui viennent
donc on n'est pas honnêtement quelques
jours près de 160 millions de chrétiens
ont été fortement persécutés dans le
monde selon les ong
l'année dernière c'est anne hidalgo qui
écope d'une amende pour non respect de
la parité alors pas dans le même sens
que d'habitude puisque il ya trop de
femmes dans son équipe à elle ce n'est
pas banal amende de 90 mille euros c'est
notre chiffre du jour que la maire de
paris juge absurde et injuste
onze femmes ont été nommées à des postes
de direction ce qui fait 69 % les
effectifs je vous présente dark vador et
un astronaute qui se retrouve notamment
au milieu de cette crise qui ne passe
pas très bien auprès des fidèles qui
sont assez surpris par cette
réinterprétation inspiré d'art
contemporain dans votre paroisse qui est
des hommes et des femmes musulmans qui
sont convertis au catholicisme y en a
dans l'église catholique à paris et en
france mais on les cache figurez vous
parce que soit c'est une exclusion
sociale qui vive
soit c'est plus dangereux
on
[Musique]